hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast hardware architecture and
its use in facilitating collaborative
development and dissemination of
microfluidic experiments presented by
dr. Carla Kim Yuna's director of
research at saben I'm julissa Morozov
labrys and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab group the leading
scientific social networking websites
and producer of educational virtual
agents and webinars before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation just click on the green
Q&A button located in the lower left of
the presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation for questions not
answered today we will follow up with
participants via email also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
icon located on the lower right of the
screen if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right at
the presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this is an educational webinar
and Ness offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on a seee button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credit please join me
in welcoming dr. quinones I will now
turn the presentation over to him hi
everyone my name is Carlo and the
director research it's Adam and a talk
today is open-source Hardware insiders
discovery I wanted to start a little bit
about Adam in our core values you know
family take a lot of pride in our
ability design the precision that we put
into our products and also the
capability that we have to build unique
design gets things started I show you
guys a great video that we took again
reach it up
is
I love that video
so fandom started in 2008 as a simple
reseller for coming dogs goddesses and
time objects to do at the time sorry and
over the years that we've expanded
services to offer service bureau works
and turnkey manufacturing for people
value add design services that help
people approve designs and optimizing
for additive manufacturing contract
manufacturing and most recently we added
a research component for companies
interested in lowering data defense
factory space we have also in Seattle in
Oakland as well as full-time staff in
China for or while you kind of made
volume reduction and by most relevant
contracting consulting services for
individuals and organizations that are
interested in exploring how 3d printing
can affect their businesses and that's
where I fit so this record research I
need those contact research projects for
other companies prior to joining fathom
that I was a postdoctoral researcher and
I'll talk a bit more about that
background but I just wanted to mention
some of the technical some of the
special affiliations in a row of its
presentation I'm part of the technical
advisory board for Lynn Forge which is a
non-profit group developed being
designed parametric designs for 3d
printable prosthetic devices prosthetic
arms
I'm also member is a Autodesk's customer
advisory board for their fusion 360 cat
soccer and probably most interesting to
you guys is an editorial board member of
the hardware acts and that's a tree and
open scientific
internal devoted sweet open scientific
hardware published by Elsevier anaxes
which means anyone can get access for
free to the journals and one of the
requirements of publication is the all
designs have to be submitted open-source
Hardware life this started last year
that's pretty exciting development that
even the somewhat stuffy industry and
scientific publishing is getting on this
open-source bandwagon it's more than a
bandwagon so
we'll start to talk to that I'll walk
you guys do a little bit of this journey
of how I got to today I promise any bad
so I love this quote Science and
Technology is addressed to the point to
what we're what we build is only
constrained by the limits or imagination
and it's inspirational in some ways and
by the end of this presentation I hope
this quote we need something different
to you but it does right now
so back in 2009 I started working with
get a so algae lab at UTSC we use
microscopes to study cells right if
you're keeping themselves alive on a
microscope you'll need to put them in an
incubator and this is the first design I
made for it's 3d printed stage topic you
mater ever it really closely parallels
the design commercially available
incubators some of the features that you
know is able to bring in because of 3d
printing is needs manifolds is
highlighted in green there is a little
tune that printed as part of the housing
what's one of my capabilities it's
really pretty business ability the print
these kind of long passages inside of
parts it used the metal to metal
aluminum tub that can provide some
thermal stability should get the heat
around and there is these two cats on
gene thin film here's attached to the
underside of that aluminum block and
that's what heated up the sample chamber
the next iteration I stopped and asked
myself why did I build a box right I
have a technology let's build any shape
I want but I built a box that's what I
began to realize how can straining that
well that everything that you've been
exposed to in this world it's being
manufactured conventionally in that
colors our expectations our assumptions
our approach to designing hardware
everything you've seen since your
account is in a box
so naturally we started in product
putting the box
questioning those kinds of assumptions
is what we do
and so some other negative is that this
design had was a sealed chamber as we
use o rings to provide an airtight seal
between the sample environment and
outside environment that gives us the
capability to capture that epilim gas
and make measurements on it you know
this is early stage it didn't want to go
too far into that capability but there
was one feature that we didn't need to
mess a rota meter which is the flow
meter right so this design is
incorporated directly into the 3d
printed housing and all it is is a paper
tube with the ball floating in the work
normally rotators are cost over $100 the
precision manufacturers but all we
needed with the simple go no-go is there
air roaming through there you know
there's no air flowing in there the
balls at the bottom the tuner there's
too much it's all the way to the top and
we designed it to that and if the ball
floating the middle we haven't left
there this is a great example of the
kind of small either features that you
can put into a design we believe almost
million in political cost with 3d
printing and the last iteration didn't
like postdoc was much more suiting built
offset when they broke free as a box the
design begins to follow the what's
happening underneath it form really
solving the underlying functionality the
part you know one of the things we had
in here we broke up that we in rock and
it's two separate people so that we
could control the amount of water that
goes into the humidification process so
how hot that is controller level
community in a separate zone for
controlling the temperature the valves
and we also managed to fit in some
commercial off-the-shelf
miniature fans either fans that were
used in devices laptops any small
economy is cooling we just using this
design we create printed out amounts
actually the mountain corporations in
2000
the chamber housing no there's one big
part that has a lot of different
functions attachments going to know that
you need to do because it's all
pronounced one part that aggregation of
selection combining all these different
functionalities in one part that is
really powerful but your design has to
start supporting that that's a little
different so as I mentioned it's like
two separate heating zones with brought
in the constant temperature zones
controlled by his own life is its own
symptom eaters and then zone and back or
conforming the amount of communication
but of course the micro fluidics is
requires a lot more than just incubation
micro fluidics is basically but the
automating the biology experiment right
because all biology experiments are just
removing liquids around from one
container to another container right
stirring and doing something that
samples and moving another container
right in you know sadly that's what you
can we break down a biology experiment
into a series would happen that's me
this is well known we've all known and
taken advantage of another another way
the big problem that we're trying to
address with this automation we don't
either micro fluidics or conventional
like what annual robotics is tackling
systems like this so this is a chart of
the cell signaling pathways of macro
feet so this is basically the circuit
that can hold your immune system it you
don't have to read it appreciate the
complexity right and it each box is
single enzyme all the connections
represent the enzymes a connected to
file chemically and this one system
exists inside the cell with other system
for calling cell cycle so that
differentiation although there's no
pathways all coexist in the same spot so
you have crop opportunites that means an
enormous challenge right so in order to
really prove this
not a dated Saturday really amazing
honor the doubt with replications in it
you're doing that many it because the
challenge ensure that the data and is
any experiments run in many laps but
they've done is use microwave microwaves
with technique where you basically
miniaturize and translate that big
liquid handling challenge into a single
small device own will turn to see their
runs on pneumatic valves on the chip and
since commutative I said worked on the
blue areas are where they're slowly
showing in this photograph I have a
video I'm going to make it a lot more
clear what's going on but by basically
opening and closing valves you can
change where the flow is moving and the
whole point of visceral small sequence
of operations this get cells seated into
six vertical changes we're adorable
device this video explaining on one so
right now those red boxes okay
everything's closed now one box one
valve jet opens now you see the cells
flowing through a chamber and shortening
another series about four open up and
the flow is diverted now it flows around
it changes so the chamber is an animal
thing seated itself it produces a gender
singular one device and that's exciting
record footage is opening and closing
valve it just happen to be very very
small valves the size of these thousands
about a 200 microns across
now that's what we did in our lives met
with nowhere close this is our this is a
paper those data art at the time the
missed a portion they use micro fluidics
to design a device capable of addressing
96 individual chambers and controlling
the media composition for that
freely automated so just this is that
little box if I highlighted one of those
changes if it's being controlled it's
not so skinny okay so now you see the
using of colored dyes wind and pumping
it into the different chambers and they
can control that on a chamber idea
basically mixing of two different media
compositions and dynamic mixing that
across all these chambers this is like
amazingly powerful technology is
available in all the publications that
you screen about this they probably
don't talk about the hardware everything
else that you need in order to make that
little device right never they show you
pictures of the bike they usually put it
next to a quarter or dying some Scott
size a reference showing you how small
it is convenient even size all the rest
isn't equipped we really not to think of
it as an entire stat right you're
running your experiment going to expect
light that means you need control
software right now install develop is
like cleaners will scientist classic
routes the microfluidic hardware you
know the series involves the intubation
all the training the plumbing to connect
everything together and then I'll find
just about there finally that that
microfluidic cartridge itself is circuit
board and that's all develops custom as
well it's what you end up is entirely
custom stack bit difficult to reproduce
your scale but when I turns this project
from Southern ina my vision was make it
a lot more robust in easier my goal was
to make it so that any work-study
student working in the labs could
actually run micro-service experiments
and so in this vision
you know relying heavily on
community-developed our open source
software but it moves on emphasize I
think unity developed because I want
emphasize that there's the technology or
the Lego developing it might put a card
where you all that good we run it in
microwave cartridges to make those
modular since it could be some a lot of
parts until quick overview we have
software running on a computer we have
some pretty printed hardware and
electronics that run the valve and the
heaters and then of course a microscope
an incubator talked about things we have
talked more about that a second so
there's an a control module I had the
sort of 40 watt 4-way full rated power
driver's serial control basically it
runs the electronics of the innovators
of stage here we have the pneumatic
control module this runs the pneumatic
valve so essentially the microscope
device has we air piloted bouts right so
if their valves that need an air
pressure source to operate and this
romantic internal models will provide
that source in a way that you control
for your computer the stage shop
incubator and when I designed this image
here to start with a template it's a
devotions with a lot more customization
on it can be customized so I started
first by building a blank slate a blank
slate for that each of each units making
QB make customized versions of it Thank
You babies very highly instrument that
they is really important for such as we
do remote something temperature of
actual heating element four or five
readings from a device the size of five
temperature readings in the plastic book
in normally and collect data over the
course of a single runs of you know a
few hours in that data all of the solid
in a straight line is what you expect or
something that's not changing with
temperature and we continuing the course
experiment but one day I acted like the
data from several days project ran up
the data collection and soft and really
interesting transient
data that correspondent bill I didn't
know what actually a little surprise
and so I follow for them so this is the
first poll I'd like to disk so okay well
take a moment to answer
all right sure is you see what you guys
say that when it turned out to be with
the door to the room we didn't want open
i ad for web camera in the room and sure
enough you know some days some people
would open the door and leave it open
the door stop down in that one cause the
temperature of these power fluctuations
in the heater in it wouldn't have that
other realization that Wow again here is
a hardware built sort of hard to be the
tightest you know very simple to commit
microprocessor microcontrollers and I
can detect whether or not the door the
room is open right there's this
generally I don't believe that you know
just wanting to get scientists talking
you know confidence or combined you bit
sometimes so act differently in
different labs you know I don't really
believe that a dollar that's true than
shows go home scientists like it's not
predictable I think the deeper truth
there is that so that differently
because environments are different in
different labs we don't appreciate and
having Richard be the sources to mind we
will go back and look for other
explanations for variability could be
very powerful tool
anyways a decent buying support
conventional like petri dish based
experiments microcytic amines and
cartridges are supporting hardware
platform the cartridges themselves and
have features such as on chip reservoirs
so rather than having to load samples up
into a separate and new separate process
right because it in depth it depends
about run microwave service here we have
on chip reservoirs and you little like a
little gas to some popular device
interlock we provided all the forms
interface rather keep those here is a
single layer valve
so normally valve my devices require two
separate layers of pmf athlete bonded
and on we take a challenge in this case
we figured out how to
single-layer valves other animations are
this cartridge the world interface so
normally as I mentioned with
marketplaces when you have a right-click
device like this you can go to running
out of there in the picture what each
one of those has to be plugged in device
manually by the experimenter will send
you not which is a real pain
this allows us to look on all the
connections at once just like you would
on the computer we also have four still
allowed replenishment or sampling of the
reservoirs this is what's shown on the
right those devices are microwave
cartridges are making 3d printing rolls
also develop its 3d printable like the
hardware J and fixture that you need
nurses do the molding of the devices a
stop reliably 3d printed hardware
devices for bonding the silicon record
device to the cloud you only use bonded
using this heavy weight couples device
down to it Wow
and this case is air pressure there's
also a lot of modularity and opportunity
to customize the functionality design so
on the left and right and I'm just
showing you the negative spaces inside
the pressure regulators the one on the
left has eight outputs and you can
control the pressure from the soccer but
it takes a good minute for you to for
the device to adjust and set point
pressure and one on the right and has
fewer outputs only has six outputs but
has much faster dynamic response or then
one can adjust with psi in under five
seconds this is a great example of how
using extended piece of hardware is
electronic you can have a very divergent
functionality by swapping out the 3d
printed portion and changing out the
firmware weight to things that is very
easy to the designs for the devices
feature-based but and the best way to
show you that this video in so this is a
plugin we've written written for fusion
360 or doing the microwave devices on
once you start to plug in just layout
food pathways the center lines the
pathways so we're just to make it very
simple T Junction and that mean box is a
big spent the max build area of the
device so we can add valves so here is
make a device where I can select media
or you know some solution coming in from
one side of the team your synthesizers
we need valve control that flow we can
switch one level on one doll off this
business reservoir on the output side
swings clanked example you can now ready
to read Marshall is two arms of the team
and at the end once you're happy with
the design again pilot has a work and
make molds and I'm using this school and
we can add other groups that can iterate
on design on a day-to-day basis so he
started designing them and they weren't
like Tuesday afternoon they're running
experiments on cast devices event
designs that the ability to iterate
quickly and reproducibly
is unparalleled another concern of
course how do you build this right leave
the current device and literally pick a
page neither one scalability
accessibility would be German so this
video to show you that's Joe used to be
one of it a shop workers at the
description student motion on a [ __ ]
machine shop we've never seen any this
hardware before we gave them
instructions and all the hardware and he
was able to assemble another working
device in about two hours
here's showing that
like that device and it's reading
printed interface and we do the
connection dollar lines and finally
digital software this is beta
micromanager rich in open-source
software developed at UCSF in such a
valence lab it's basically a platform
for automating any microscope the
plugins in it for our controlling the
finest hardware and you see here is and
how you control this low pass and
basically it's about being in state
either flowing media we're not throwing
the media I'm applying flow from the
adjunct reservoirs or you can see how
this book paths which you cannot control
the setpoint
number right in the bottom light front
control manifolds you see the pressure
set point in the dial States responding
and reapplying you know isn't
open-source software knows this what
does where am I the program project
ended you know fortunately recently have
had a chance to revisit these projects
and keep pushing forward on it so
remember this is where we left off this
is this is the last iteration in me at
UCSD able to completely brilliant
authentically and so this is where I
went out the second poll what would you
do next right where would you take this
design
now very hasten to the result that I
want to rock this well even I actually
find this quote depressing if your
technology can peel right now of course
you're very proud of the technology but
as an engineer scientist it's saying
that our imagination we played it's not
technology we can build things that we
can't even imagine yet our imagination
is that what's holding us back and
realize that over time many men here
working with it so I took upon myself to
get rid of the metal right can we make
an incubator that didn't rely on metal
so even we have metal incubators is that
we're relying on the passive thermal
conductivity remember these designs you
know there's this relatively high
concentrated heat source that thin film
heater and we want to spread that evenly
around control like temperature
fluctuations I'm sorry and control
temperature fluctuations if there's lots
of good reasons we've metal is one thing
I don't like about metal if it can't
well you can't be that supportive yes
we're working so but you know their
design exercise cavity right now so I
started focusing on that incident my
first ad at that it uses a blower
zaraki's it to push air through this
really complex stock work and the green
light green vertical kind of things are
commuters and so dots distribute the
heated air around the surface this is a
proof of concept right and Mike Ranney
can you actually build another without
using that and it actually works
surprisingly well you know some of the
things they realize or notice was that
even though the plastic was hot it felt
much cooler the content was also very
very responsive to changes and
temperature right so if you said that
your set point it responded very quickly
um
this led to my next project taking one
step further this is project Pyrrha it's
a fully 3d printed oven we would Nestle
in technology so the plastic resin is
actually a food person contacts the fan
underneath which we printed out those
green elements are still normal heaters
so electrical see if I can that
aggressive device is pretty printed so
there's three hundred watts or total
heaters in the base that can keep them
entertained what the degree Celsius the
bottom is rated for up to creating axes
there's some things that are integrated
directly with walls a distributed scheme
and the humid air flows up into the
right in the passageway you know they're
generated so that the cross-sectional
area means Clips all the way through I
mean you know some of the talent
redeployment I don't expect people only
but you know highlight learn how to
build kind of convective convective
that's and some things with different
occupations and you know where it'll we
plan one out it worked and we actually
cook some steak with it people asking
what it tastes like
guys likes what they pay from victory
because maybe my boffin think it would
work
let's research and invite you to go to
our website and watch videos about
project hiring I was going into the
school project Pyrex learn more about it
are one of the current research projects
we have is pushing this technology next
set forward project crucible is kind of
build up will be learned in pyro to
develop an incubator for doing
xenobiology or stream of biology
specialty but the incubator is capable
of creating a near vacuum right so we
had to figure out a new air tight at the
end printing as well as going down to
minus 80 degrees Celsius and controlling
the light levels inside so this top the
fans on the top are actually a chauffeur
30 while moving interior contents the
goal for this department this is using
it to explore how to do synthetic
biology optimized organisms are on Mars
and in cities to make Martian
environment your vacuum [ __ ] white
levels and suppose my descendants LTS a
little bit of dying set we figured out
how did it really make inflation or how
to optimize communicating and bill for
insulated property novel twice herbs in
order to get it to print out your type
art and ultimately the design has 9 3d
printing pieces and the tops for
everything except our swing was not
shown in the picture of course is the
huge chiller the cryogenic chiller is
like 30 grand and then the vacuum
proximate to grant the cost of 3d
printing out of the components and but a
half gram so like out the door you're
looking at like 50 grand to get this
whole thing up and running a
conventionally manufactured its own
incubator that can be conditions on Mars
and there's two of them this planet one
here in the US winter we are a Europe
I'm sorry a lot of quarter-million
dollars totally bespoke engineering
maintenance and scalability is hampered
by the cost and the different
manufacturing approaches 3d printing
kind of opens that up I wanted to show
you a video about what when I am
inspired by and what I'd like to figure
out a priest biology this is um
Cindy Neha do produce the factory that's
1,000 times cleaner than a hospital
operating room it all begins with the
waiver then disk of pure silicon a
nonmetallic natural element that
conducts electricity and automated
container system moves the wafer through
more than 800 operations and each stop
the wafer receives one of several layers
of non conductive materials such as
silicon dioxide and conductive material
such as copper the machines coat the
layer with light-sensitive fluid then
apply UV light through a glass stencil
of the complex pattern of electrical
circuitry the exposed areas of fluid
chemically react locking the material
directly underneath into the circuitry
matter chemical past then removed the
surrounding fluid and material leaving
only the layer of circuitry electrical
pathways 2,000 times narrower than a
human hair a robot test the circuitry
for every memory chip on the wafer a
single wave measuring 12 inches in
diameter for hundreds of memory chips
the goal is to make those chips as small
as possible in this industry it's all
about maximum memory in minimal space
that's why this operation thins the
chips by grinding away two thirds of the
silicon from the backside of the wafer
and one last before cutting the wafer
into individual memory chips this
machine applies tape to hold the
separating chips together
a computer-guided saw slices the chips
apart cutting silicon is like cutting
glass it requires a diamond edge blade
in the next step a robotic are following
the wafer map generated earlier except
the tubes which pass testing and it
catches each one to a fiberglass seat
frame the term lead refers to the frames
pins when you connect the chip to the
digital device another robot wires the
chip to the lean frame with gold thread
that's about the width of a human hair
Gold is very conductive so now the
pathway is complete so as well house me
but you know when I found it I was
struck by how similar manufacturing a
semiconductors allows you to both batch
things processes we saw instead of
actually have taken at the samples the
wavers around a facility the different
machines you do one operation on one
machine then you have to take the weight
route of the sample to the next machine
the next operation and so on this has so
many parallel biology we have station
via people that do things and I wanted
you know send kind of think me into that
to understand what how they got there
it was really really interesting was
that they got there by accident
so Smith stands for standard mechanical
airbase format their automation
solutions did it did it like arrived
because they were looking for how to
automate the process they were looking
for a solution to the problem of later
accounting so in the that to feature
sizes on microchips began to shrink even
the cleanest clean rooms were to dirty
and so there's minhwan the Smith box
something beginning basically the box is
a super cool room it's so you still have
the same number of particles per cubic
meter they can normally have it
this myth boxes kind of appliances
honestly have the same hundred particles
per box and now all those particles are
one small corner and waiters are safe
and so you're designing that system it
was very suitable quickly that then they
decided that they wanted to be
programmed the machine and so their
first iteration Smith Box awesome create
circuitry the set the settings on the
spin coater right so in this box
attached in spin coating machine it
outside the settings for the RPM suspend
sign everything out so that the sample
itself began to carry around
instructions to the different machine
today you know that's done through
networks another way but that path of
providing a secure state environment
that's tractable auditable environment
for your samples was where automation
started right you solve the real problem
example problems and automation build
off that and I've been thinking about
how to do this lousy and I think it does
involve a community effort in microcosm
the semiconductor industry was
standards-based groups and in other
exactly read some other example I think
one another think that is incredibly
inspiring is opening and King project
it's a losing not familiar with this
it's a collaborative effort among big
tech companies to develop an open-source
alternative to the praia Terry rack
mount servers on the lab teaching
traditional ones on frightens me the
open source ones from Open Compute
Project first thing you'll notice that
cog night there's no as well right
that seems about ten tons of plastic
waste when building a single data center
and not only that the server is also run
cooler and more efficiently in cooler
being more reliable the bevels disappear
here their well which begs the question
who decided to put bezels on servers
right it wasn't an engineer who said
this is the best decision we users
develop hardware they end up in a very
different outcome getting rid of edward
cosmetics with some functional like side
effect more interestingly is that the
architecture itself began to work from
conventional servers the time they're
eight blade servers were the trend in
big IT enterprise infrastructure and a
blade server is basically a small core
you know the size of get back books a
not a stick but about that dimension
with the cpu in the memory on it and
those would slide into a box on your
rack and that's how you would add
servers to it with Open Compute Project
it right back with a rack module like
when you sweat of nothing but CPUs in a
separate rack module of nothing but RAM
and this is interesting and powerful
capability because now he can create
virtual servers like one gigabyte server
with two big ran out by sorry one one
seeking server with the gig ram or four
CPM server with 18 three a 32 c team
server with on a 28 grand all of that is
done dynamic configuration rather than
relying on that that laid architecture
which is hardwired capability there's
other incremental improvements a maze of
switching the main supply voltage from
128 for you easy in the list is very
long
it's take a long time to get there but
coming to the implement business was
started by state so it just made the
people to state over a billion dollars
by switching to developing your own
hardware collaboration will company data
centers that are built with open on Open
Compute Project set and at a cost
when is 28% less build and 30% less to
operate the other be more efficient
we've been ok project even set by
air conditioning how to do their
conditioned air comes as far as moves a
part of this project
a lot of big tech companies are
contributing to this one point I'm one
of them I have our home here that
open-source people think of open-source
contributors as being individual
engineers right the guy is living home
we're going to bras or packing away this
is especially true in the hardware space
people think of open sources makers and
Instructables right amateurs and I don't
use that word in that pejorative sense
of amateur is not guilt it's somebody
who's doing it I like the Latin roots
the word amateur originally the word net
I mean one love swimming
mammoth roaring Aman is the book one is
paid into it and so that's that's that's
what I need like most open source
computers making general amateurs Open
Compute even here's our paper with
Google introduced with a source project
because they get months they made money
using this technology we both ate there
days or so in space book and open source
projects among big companies drives
changes and there's been a great example
Linux is another good example that the
cop that made possibly proving links
colonel per day we didn't use 25 billion
dollars we didn't think that that grew
organically with no direct costs so
anymore
it's free and open for everybody
everyone uses any powers with modern use
become other examples is open successful
open source Harvard project elbow so
this is an open source camera system all
the Google Street View cars are built
off of L total architecture at least the
cameras are right people use it uses to
Berlin starting from scratch and we have
their contributions back into the
community benefits telling people to
write the very kind of community
user centric approach to development
lightweight innovation prepares is
another good example is looking to
Newark project the kind of reimagine how
student or fight production grain
production clinical slide it vacuums
quote what we can do in biology
infrastructure lies the hardware but we
have the technology to make something
entirely different that works for
everyone better than what we have today
you have to be able to imagine to listen
closing thoughts and this is running
still recommend to take this is a slide
that they have on our homepage right
take control of your technology futures
the open biotech projects is reimagining
Hardware making more efficient flexible
and scalable joiner load needs
technology leaders working together
break open the black box proprietary
biotech infrastructure critique greater
towards customization and cost savings
why don't we have this right biotech is
interesting we didn't shoot worth
billions of dollars with company that
has hundreds of bike trained mechanical
engineers we can take control of our
technology if you're not relying out by
providers whose interest is playing
plastic bezel on boxes rather our focus
is on getting better data more more
reproducible we invite more scalable
here's my contact information please
feel free to reach out or follow me on
Twitter if you guys are interested in
this project thank you doctor too
is for that informative presentation we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the brain Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on your screen and click on this pin
button will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for if we are
unable to get to your question we will
follow up with you via email after the
presentation let's get started
the first question is where can i
download download copies of the designs
[Music]
the designs right now I have if you're
familiar with fusion 360 it's a cat
Bopper from resentiment today is that
part of that opera is the ability to
share repository add data music loud
centric data source model so it contact
me I'll send you an invite so that that
repository of information it's a little
while warning for the one structuring
like elaborate CAD data can be linked in
dance and hard to get through and one of
the things that we'd like to do is kind
of thing it up and make it more
accessible to somebody or given silence
field is near that's a matter with it um
but again continue to kind of kind of
you know also getting that of that but
you won't get a copy of engine 360 that
software is free for anybody macademia
so to stop me no address you get a free
lesson performing at night it's also
free for startups or you'll get it for
one-year license for free if you make
less than a thousand dollars a year at
the start of and otherwise I can
probably afford with it's great at both
work yeah so I'll add you with all
stories alive act honesty and can
certainly appreciate me help them
improving line forward
thank you
the next question is how does someone
get involved in this project
oh that's a good question
um a tough one and you know it is a
project I've been working on for a long
time you need to target this maybach
thousand nine minute in some of the
times I had early on we're getting
people excited about this right we can
go scientist camping see this like a
results-oriented information me I think
the biggest thing to do to help being
involved in this communicating to other
people if there's an alternative and
certainly if you have other employment
so there's communication getting at
people inside about this because I think
one of the big coops or
it's kind of open architecture would be
the benefits to education basic denim
right swimming school University don't
have access to modern scientific
equipment that they may have access to
3d printer that would give us the
ability to even create like modern
equipment I think it could learn the
same kinds of hardware it means to
really fill settings we keep Linux right
the software you learn is the same
talking engines in industry we can do
that provisos well and so it's you know
one a help volunteer get something set
up at a local school or on a project
that'd be great too and finally and if
you have any other ideas for how to help
you get involved we just want to say a
personal dislike definitely appreciate
that again and clean contact
unfortunately not as much as I'd like
you know some of my responsibilities
here I can vote some folks around here
like internal enterprises all network
that we're getting here is modernize our
infrastructure in production we're all
good but you know there is some there is
some opportunity here at work to do some
high-impact contract project but I also
know a lot of Engineers that are
familiar with this architecture it
especially to help out on projects again
it really depends in specific and how
in-depth it in going in for a good
project that also has marketing impact
it actually widens your grade one thing
I've learned is with our research is
that the output research is really
marketing writing scientist you're
trying to market your ideas and get them
we're standing forward which is
essentially what resources we only eight
so one good opportunities for like
market means all right project bad
marketing act or the way more likely to
get we will get on your bottom
otherwise I have friends I know people
can help please reach out